bientôt la fin du simple allumage et
extinction à chevreuse les 1000 points
lumineux de la commune vont s'adapter
aux besoins en éclairage liées à la
sécurité et à la circulation avec cette
totale rénovation la commune pourra
choisir notamment l'intensité de
l'éclairage on est en train de créer un
groupe de travail technique dans lequel
on associera les gendarmes pour l'aspect
sécurité le parc naturel pour l'aspect
environnemental et puis un certain
nombre de techniciens et quelques élus
et on va travailler sur le plan de la
commune en dif en en ciblant différents
types dax on envisage à partir de cette
cartographie de différencier les
périodes c'est à dire alors je vous
donne un exemple je sais pas si on
s'arrêtera à cet exemple là mais sur un
axe très circulé on fera peut-être
qu'une baisse d'intensité dans la nuit
de 30 ou 40% par exemple pour remonter
vers 5-6 heures du matin en fonction des
usages un projet pensé par la mairie il
ya un an d'un montant d'un million
d'euros cent cinquante mille sont
financés par la région ile-de-france le
projet est aussi soutenue à 50% par
l'état
la commune a obtenu un financement de
500 mille euros du plan france relance
dont on est vraiment au début du
dispositif puisque c'est un marché qu'on
a lancé l'année dernière et sur lequel
dès le départ l'état a souhaité nous
accompagner dans la première vague
finalement des projets qui ont été
soutenues dans le cadre de france
relance ce financement du plan rentrer
dans la dotation de soutien à
l'investissement local pour financer les
grandes priorités d'investissement des
communes et de leurs groupements
ce renouvellement permettra à la commune
de faire une réduction de 60 % de sa
consommation d'énergie on le sait tous
un le prix de l'énergie flamber je pense
que
même si les dates sont annoncées au
printemps prochain on ira à long terme
de toute façon pas sur une tendance
baissière au niveau de la facture ça va
pas se répercuter tout de suite mais ce
qu'il faut se dire c'est que si on était
resté sur l'ancien système en dehors des
pannes récurrentes et c'est notre
consommation auraient augmenté
de manière forte 80 collectivités
territoriales dans les yvelines se sont
vus attribuer des fonds de france
relance d'un budget de 100 milliards
d'euros sur deux ans 30 milliards de ce
plan sont dédiés à la transition
écologique